oggi faremo un altro falli risponde come
quello della settimana scorsa dove mi
avete fatto domande scomode ed è stato
molto molto triste perché con il prof
tante domande private
però questa volta facciamo un po più
easy che avete sempre mandato le domande
di direct che io risponderò e niente
direi che possiamo cominciare a leggere
le fossero bambini con domare una voglia
di essere in questo video
siamo proprio sicuri di volerlo tenere
qua siccome mi avete fatto un miliardo
di domande ed è impossibile decisamente
impossibile beccare tutte grazie a dio
l'onor 10 alla gpu turbo e quindi riesco
a leggere tutte le domande
cioè l'elenco tutte però non posso
rispondere a tutte rega impossibile però
mi siedo perché sto veramente somma
giuria mi scrive consiglieresti milan
come citato un ragazzo ragazza che vuole
andare a vivere da solo dal tuo punto di
vista
cosa ti piace maggiormente cosa invece
proprio non ti piace alla milano alla
città piega ci sta mi piace l'arte mi di
milano in parte bellissima
dovete restando che se dovessi c'è
l'alta milano prova l'altra finale
veramente bella bellissima
in realtà e milano e molto nightlife nel
senso fa in molti in discoteca ste cose
qua solo che io non lo faccio perché se
non possono salate a fare i tempi quindi
sta a casa e guardo barbara d'urso quasi
a nove circoli hanno amore e affetto
nella tua vita allora l'amore e
l'affetto nella mia vita sono due cose
molto importanti di polvere cane prima
solo che a di olio la folla quindi
quando sto in mezzo alla gente li può
non mi sento appiccicoso dove però le
persone che vi stanno a cuore
hanno un ruolo importante nella mia vita
quindi per me l'amore l'affetto nella
mia vita tranne quando cambierà il look
dei tuoi capelli ancora quando inizierò
a perderlo da piccolo che sport e facevi
ti piace il calcio allora da piccolo io
giocavo a calcio però datelo con un
piccolo lavorativo cinque anni ho
giocato quattro anni in uno stato di
calcio del mio paesino tra l'altro uomo
in sette nel mio paesino fatti la
squadra non lo davamo facciamo schifo io
soprattutto perché io ero molto timido
come bambino qui giochiamo bene quando
giocavo contro i miei amici ma con 3000
altre squadre di altri paesi facevo
schifo
una volta abbiamo giocato contro la
juventus abbiamo
3 2 a 0 32 me lo ricordo molto bene ha
fatto male il sederino in quel periodo
alice mi chiede quanti fidanzate aiuto
nella tua vita fidanzate proprio storie
serie 3 3 storia serie 3 storielle 28
qual è la prima canzone quale l'ha
scritto senza apostrofo fantasma qual è
la prima canzone che ti riporta
immediatamente indietro nel tempo
facendoti ricordare gli anni passati
quando era piccolo avresti mai pensato
di diventare una persona famosa
crescendo
no perché ero molto timido ripeto perché
io quand'ero piccolo anche adesso però
quando andavo a scuola mi sedevo sempre
secondo perché devo fare la pena quando
di queste cose per è vero mi sedevo in
fondo è che la gente mi dà fastidio
quindi vediamo tutti no non è vero per
carità però ero molto timido quindi non
pensavo mai di diventare conosciuto a
tutti i compari c'erano agli voglio
diventare come voglio che la gente mi
riconosca per strada io dicevo a me
preme però è successo a me per carità
ogni volta che provavo quando sono
contento e non è che per anzi se volete
chiedermi tranquilli non c'è problema
però no nessuno sa rispondere alla
domanda dove basta uno solo che dopo
arriva dieci minuti sono come si
monetizza qual è ti piace il grana no mi
piace il grano i tuoi che cosa hanno
pensato quando ha iniziato a fare dito
su youtube
quando event ed aprendo su youtube io
facevo schifo a scuola cioè nel senso
prendevo sempre ruote berruti
tutto poi nostra era sociale facevo
schifo quindi la vita mia era fantastica
allora ho iniziato a fare video su
youtube quindi nonostante i disagi che
provavano i genitori di votare portavo
le pagelle voti brutti e hanno iniziato
a sentirmi urlare dalla camera bene a
tutti ragazzi quindi cairo sotterrato
della stima dei miei genitori
quindi quando iniziato a urlare però
tutti ragazzi dopo un annetto l'indizio
trasferito minato qual è stato il
momento più più ansiogeno più ansiogeno
ansiogeno della tua vita ansiogeno
questo perché non sapevo come leggere la
parola ansiogeno rafael non raul e ora
file tra burell te possino cosa ne pensi
dell'adozione a distanza di sasha beh
penso che l'adozione a distanza sia una
cosa fantastica
quindi fascia sabrina hanno fatto una
grandissima cosa se ne avete la
possibilità a fartelo amico lo farò
sicuramente inizierò adottando sasha
cosa pensi di noi fan che ti seguiamo
sempre
mettete a rifarlo perché mi mette pazzi
cioè nel senso proprio di seguirmi se
vado in giro non mi se guardatemi
accoglie basta eseguite anche lorenzo
michele grande lorenzo finalmente un non
per cento nome perché sei maschio perché
dicevo solo domande da ragazze che va
bene per carità però sembra playboy ma
non ho capito comunque descrivi la tua
adolescenza
i tre parole che però deve censurare sia
ricca che perché sono insieme mi prendi
come passerai le tue giornate quando
sarai vecchio e così esattamente così
col cane al posto del cavallo
chiamando cosa ti manca di più della tua
vita quando ancora non eri popolare
beh ovviamente potrà andare in giro
tranquillamente senza perché alla fine
ogni tanto no stress che non possono
dare in spiaggia non posso andare al
centro commerciale non posso fare una
camminata se troppo in centro queste
cose qua purtroppo e poi in quel periodo
di giocare un sacco di poi videogiochi
in generale con quei miei amici perché
era il periodo in cui parlavamo la
scuola non facevamo una mazza se non
giocare videogiochi e non avevamo sky
quei tempi e va bene il museo e quindi
mi attaccavo il telefono alla maglietta
e parlavo al telefono con nicolas e che
va vengono ceduti giocavamo a beauty
insomma curatore mi divertivo da morire
è stato per un bel periodo della mia
vita
l'unica roba e che poi veramente
crescendo cambiano le abitudini che
brutto invecchiato però alcune cimici
nuovi tipo coperta di c'era marco
merlino è bellissima la vita non sai mai
che cosa ti riserva ma i cavi chiede
racconta un tuo momento imbarazzante
grazie marica che li metti sempre a mio
agio nei miei video e complimenti allora
momenti imbarazzanti ce ne sono stati
tanti alla mia vita cioè dal mattino
alla sera potrei faccio un video però
uno in particolare è successo tre anni
fa e ci sono andato al concerto di avere
grande una cugina e mi ero ovviamente
imbacuccato dalla testa che dà voce
raccontato sta roba una volta provare il
racconto in sanremo mi ero tipo messo il
turbante per non farmi conoscere robe
incredibili sono andato a fare la fila
per entrare dentro l'arena era pieno di
bambini ne facciamo finta di niente
tutto bardato è andato tutto bene finché
una ragazza non non mi ha guardato
proprio bene bene e ha riconosciuto che
ero io
ha urlato il mio nome vabbè è stato the
walking dead money never shaun giulia
michele c'è allora e come procedere
state molto bene grazie giulia passano
caldo bestia vorrei morire ma non fa
niente
poi soprattutto per il fatto che quando
artisti di video non puoi tenere la
ventilatore attaccato se non si sente
quindi quando voi mi vedete nei video in
realtà in quello retta che sto
registrando mi sto divertendo ma sto
soffrendo come un cane
hai mai desiderato avere una sorella più
piccola se sì come l'avresti chiamarla
tra va beh innanzitutto se io adesso con
la sorella non aveva chiamata io perché
c'è aspetta che ci si deve chiamare una
piccola sorella puoi sia data una
sorella
no perché avrei dovuto condividere
dell'iss max in italy con delle persone
nelle persone o caldo adesso non c'è
cosa sta facendo
anzi no è bellissimo non potrei capire
ci siamo dopo più così quindi ragazzi
questa era il pavé risponde spero che mi
sia piaciuto in realtà è da un po che ci
pensavo di farne un paio fatti questo è
il secondo rigore risponde che faccio in
poco tempo perché devo perché mi è
venuto in mente di riportare questo
format visto che era da un po che non lo
fa
però al rientro delle vacanze ho
preparato un paio di format chiesto
quando me li riporteranno un po indietro
nel tempo e sono fiero di me stesso in
questo periodo come un sacco chiedere
quindi ragazzi tutto il video faceva
parte anche della mette il turbo
challenge visto che sto usando non 10 e
a proposito della mette il turbo fate un
video anche voi pubblicato su instagram
collasso lasciata più lasciatagli e io
lavoro sul web numero uno con la nascita
che mette il turbo rubricati video così
li quando i ragazzi io spero che mi sia
piaciuto di giuro registrare i video
senza il climatizzatore e la morte però
si diverte fa youtube cioè fatto i nomi
ha detto ci si sciogliere però è
divertente e bello fare per il team
all'inverno quindi ragazzi spero che i
fatti mi che sono mayhew tuber il tipo
in danimarca si sballano i loro sterile
rimarca primi 20 per cento ragazzi cosa
non mi piace proprio realmente
l'estizione sono chiesti ha detto cimino
[Musica]